- Not everybody is meant for greatness.
Not everybody has an
extreme talent in a category
that produces money,
but everybody does have a talent
that can produce happiness
as long as, if you're a great artist,
you know that you're not
gonna make ten billion,
and as long as you're making ten billion,
that you know that maybe
you're not gonna be
the most noble.
You've gotta just be true.
You just have to know what
you're gonna be about.
You have to accept yourself,
and not worry about what
everybody else thinks,
and go all in on you.
(urban pop music)
If you're at South By
Southwest come check it.
I'm heading to the convention center,
about to get my keynote,
12:30 PM, come see me.
Details in the text below.
(urban pop music)
Fuckin' line is crazy.
Look, I'm speaking.
- What time do you speak?
- In an hour, one of the keynotes.
- You speak in an hour,
go to that very far,
oh, get on there.
- Go where?
- That very far, over
there, speaker info.
- Hurry.
Hurry.
Looking fresh bro.
- Appreciate it.
- After three days.
Every three days.
- I like your fade.
- Thank you man.
I got a really good guy.
- It's looking tight.
- I got a really good guy.
I put him on snapchat the
other day, it was funny.
He was like, "What is this?"
He thought it was so cool.
- Someone fucked up,
and they sent the bracelet confirmation
to everybody who RSVP'd,
and so now everyone thinks
they have a VIP bracelet.
- If you live in the state of Texas,
get your ass to book people tonight, 6 PM.
I will be there with a live event,
really looking forward to it.
What time is it?
- [Man] 12:25.
- [Woman] 12:25.
- Beautiful.
(clapping)
Thank you guys, I appreciate it.
Thanks for being here.
I'm gonna do a quick
survey of how many people
know me and don't know me.
Based on that, I will speed
up the process of what
we're really here to do,
which is straight up Q and
A in your fuckin' mouth.
(laughter and clapping)
I wanna do some sort of weird contest.
(laughing)
- [Woman] (shouts) Take a selfie!
- Right now?
- [Woman] Yeah, you have
everybody behind you man.
Have everybody go up there,
and take a selfie with
everyone behind you.
(laughter)
- (laughs) She's bringing it.
I'm definitely now doing
that because I like
to fight the system.
I love you, see ya.
(cheering and clapping)
Thank you.
So, what's the problem?
- [Woman] He needs more support.
- Well fuckin be patient.
(laughter)
How old is he?
- [Woman] He's 35.
- You're fuckin young bro.
What are worried about?
It's not gonna happen overnight.
Nobody understands about entrepreneurship
and philanthropy working
together in Europe.
Like you need to be patient.
You need to grind.
Something great doesn't
happen just because
you did it for a couple years,
or 7 years, or 13 years.
You have to chip away,
chip away, chip away.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Can I get the mic?
Guys can I get the mic for one second
about the book signing?
Can I get the mic for one second?
Shit!
That would've been fun.
- You said six right?
- Yes, I'll see you at six brother.
I'll see you.
Thanks for all your help.
No.
Alright.
(shouts) I'm doing a
book signing somewhere!
- Thank you.
- Hey Gary.
- Very early on in my career
he wanted me to be like
the next food network star.
So, I meet him, it was really cool.
This was before the internet was real,
and I was like, "Whoa (bleep)."
You know?
He was a really kind of not
a great guy in my opinion,
but he did say one thing that
has always stuck with me.
He said, "Gary, you never go on TV
"until the CD's in the stores."
He talked about why
his method was working.
People would promote a week
before the album was out,
and there was no way to
get it the next moment
at your height of emotion.
Way too many people in
tech talk a big game before
their products come.
They think that hype is
gonna do them anything.
All that hype is gonna do
is clown them in the end.
- We play soccer at Mount Ida.
- Get the fuck out of here.
- Yes, that's where.
- it's the Ida baby, New Mass.
- Newton baby.
- Newton.
(urban pop music)
Action.
Love it.
- Yeah.
- Ah, love it.
- Awesome name.
Stay well.
Awesome, hope you enjoyed the book.
- I am a journalist now.
- Thank you so much, it's a pleasure.
- Good to meet you, how are things?
- You're an inspiration.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, let's have a conversation.
That's just crucial.
- Years ago, and I've been--
- Thank you.
- Perfect, thank you.
- What's up Latoya's crew.
- [Girl] This dude right
here is a rock star.
- It's me Gary Vee.
- [Girl] Get off your butts.
- Get off em'.
Now.
(laughter)
So fun.
Big ups to my boy Guy.
Guy thank you so much for
the Facebook Live shout out.
DRock throw that up.
I like the way Guy's
playing the facebook live.
Guy's always got first
mover advantage skills.
He knows what's up on facebook live.
Guy I wanna talk to you
about the size of this book.
I've been thinking about
doing some more micro,
kind of, I like what you did here.
I think I need to put out
more versions of this.
I can see a compliment to
the ask Gary Vee volumes
in little theses like "Ask
Gary Vee Around Artists."
These are interesting to me.
My man, Brian, you're genius.
Brian Grazer, great great great guy.
Frank, I mean look at this.
Frank Gruber, one of my buddies.
My first South By I hung out with Frank.
We drank wine together.
It's good to see your book here Frank.
Uh-oh.
Now this, this is the section.
Ries, right here DRock.
Love this guy.
This book was a beast.
This was a big selling book.
I like David a lot.
A gentleman.
Check him out, a real good human.
Real good human.
Alright.
Do your thing.
Just showing everybody
the autograph stickers.
I like these autograph stickers.
DRock, I'm gonna put one on you.
I'm gonna autograph DRock.
- We've got a lot of
people already onboard,
I wanna see if you were interested in--
- These are Magic the
Gathering entrepreneur cards?
- You got it homey, you're so fast.
- I tend to be fast.
Can I be like the overlord
most valuable one?
Or do I kind of have
to have my proper spot,
which is in the upper tier,
but there's some people?
- You're up here.
We get a lot of good--
- This is cool man.
I'm thrilled to do it.
- There's a fresh pack for you.
There's my card.
- Awesome man.
Good luck to you.
Stay well.
- I got nothing, I just wanna say hi.
I was in episode 100.
- Yes.
- And it's a privilege to
finally talk to you man.
- Thank you brother.
Secret powers Ronnie,
secret powers, and DRock.
- Hey Gary, good to see you!
- [Gary] Good to see you.
How are you?
What's going on?
Hold on, I gotta hop on it here.
- Please help Bonin (laughs).
Yo Bonin, why aren't
you putting out content
on your Snapchat.
We're starting out right now Gary.
Don't worry about it, I'm gonna catch you.
- Never.
Nine years of hanging,
what's your Snapchat?
It's good to see you brother.
- You look like you're shrinking.
- I am shrinking, I'm
getting fit, I'm getting fit.
- You always post those videos
of you playing ball, yeah?
- Yeah.
- [Man] Do you still play every morning?
- I'm playing once a week.
Once every ten days.
- [Man] All we're talking about--
- [Gary] Great.
(laughter)
- Listen, listen Gary.
All we're talking about
is going back to like 1997
permission based relationships,
Seth Godin, sort of--
- Yeah, I mean, look, I don't--
- He's talking cell phones,
so we're talking about a
permission based marketing,
direct marketing relationship.
- I think--
- There's always been permission, right?
- Yeah, I mean, look.
I think it depends on how you look at it.
Do I think new things happen?
Not that often.
I think everybody's being fucked
with because the attention
is being staggered in so
many different directions,
and shifts very quickly.
If you were all of our parents.
Our moms and dads.
If they were marketers a generation ago,
they had it easy.
We had a consistent platform of marketing
for a very long time. The internet,
that's the thing being delivered
in the phone by the way.
That thing screwed it up.
It's tough now, sorry.
Do you think I'm happy that
Twitter's losing it's attention?
I have 1.2 million followers on it.
(laughter)
I was a top of the heap.
I was winning.
I'm super pissed, I'm sad,
I'm not happy about it,
but I'm not crying about it.
I'm learning, and executing,
and instagram, and Snapchat,
and that's just the way it is.
It's gonna move fast and what we have,
and again, because Bonin's here,
and the context of a lot
of people in the room.
In a corporate environment, again,
the whole thing in mistructured.
You have brand managers.
These are business operators.
These are people that
think about profit margin,
actually the formula of the cookies,
they have to think about
their relationships
with their retailers.
On top of all of that,
they have to understand
what's going on in marketing,
and they, and some
random creative director
from Wieden and Kennedy get
to decide what the creative
is that they're gonna
spend all their money on.
It's such a fucked up system.
It makes no common sense in a 2016 world,
and there's a reason so many
people struggle to sell shit
because they don't know how.
That's why I think it's happening.
- What's your name?
- Kat Walk.
- Yeah.
Shoot me a meow (laughs).
- Great, thank you.
- Very well.
- Hi.
- [Man] Hi.
- Awesome, stay well.
Get in here Sheila.
- I'm Sheila, nice to meet you.
- How are you doing darling?
- I'm good.
You inspire me everyday on Snapchat.
- Thank you Sheila.
- Because this shit makes my head hurt,
and I watch how you use it, and I'm like,
"Fuck, I am going to
do what that guy does."
- Yes.
- Get it Sheila.
- Good for you.
- Thank you, good for you.
- Thank you for saying that.
- Hi.
- Hi, can I get a signed copy too?
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
That was good panel right?
- That was awesome.
- Who do you wanna make it out to?
- To me, Anna.
- A-N-N-A?
- [Anna] Yes.
- That is good.
Hustlin'.
- 24-7 brother.
- I see it all on the Snapchat.
- Thank you brother, I wish you well.
- [Woman] I'm sorry--
- Gary V-E-E, get in.
Hey Steph.
- How are you?
- Good to see you, I'm really well.
- Amazing as always.
- Thank you.
- I need a personally signed book.
- You got it.
- Awe, love you.
- Love you very much.
- So proud of you.
- Thank you.
- It was amazing.
- Crazy right?
- This book is really happening.
- So good.
- Thank you, good to see you.
There are some books at Kunk's Gallery.
Come and get them DRock.
Awesome.
- Awesome, thank you.
- It's great to see you again.
Thanks for all the support.
I appreciate the love on social.
- Of course.
I'm always there for you.
- Dropping that real talk.
- Every time.
- Always bro.
- Good luck to you man.
- Go hard on Snapchat.
- Go hard?
- Hard, hard, syphon every
eyeball you have to follow you.
- Only way?
- It's gonna really matter.
Hyphen everything you've
got into this channel.
That's where the attentions
gonna be in 2019,
be there or lose.
- You heard it, right here.
#AskGaryVee.
- Good to see you brother.
(urban pop music)
- [Man] It's something
that I think if we do it
the right way you can
create something that is
much more sustainable.
- 100%.
- Right?
You're not gonna miss your
kid's graduations and all that,
but then the more--
- I'm not even willing to miss Jet games.
- I have to tell people no on Sundays,
and they think I'm kidding (laughs).
That happens regularly.
(laughter)
- How about Thursday?
Thursday night, until
the schedule comes out,
we don't book Thursday
nights in the fall because
we literally are scared
it's the one Jet game.
So funny.
- They're like, "Huh?"
"Like, is it religious?"
I'm like, "No."
- You should start answering yes.
(laughs)
Have you heard of the rare Jets religion?
It's so fun to be here.
I remember going down here for a party.
God, man, it's unbelievable
how much has changed
in the nine years I've been coming here.
(urban pop music)
Me and the team have been talking,
and I'm really feeling
that this book has allowed
me to be what I really am.
You know, it's funny,
I think the first chapter speaks
to what the entire book is,
and ironically is the first
film DRock ever made with me,
which is Clouds and Dirt, right?
This book, if you've read
it, or when you read it,
I think you'll see has the
Crush It!, Thank You Economy,
kind of philosophies of
what the big issues at hand,
self awareness kind of, the
emotional EQ, kind of heady,
philosophical, anthropology
kind of stuff going on,
but then it also has very
tactical posts like this,
and use this for very tangible advice.
So, it's been interesting
for me to see whether
it's a Scoble, or Guy Kawasaki,
or other people saying,
"Whoa, this is a really How To book."
Like, this is not a fluff
book, this is really like,
thing to things, do these things,
like there's things to be done.
Then other people saying, "Whoa."
Other people writing reviews are like,
"Gary's finally grown up."
"This really talks about
the bigger things."
I think there's too many
people writing business books
that have never built a business.
They make money on teaching
people how to make money
when they've never made
money in any way besides
teaching people how to make money.
I have a lot of cynicisms to that,
and I have a lot of cynicism
to the overall place
where entrepreneurship is right now.
I'm excited for this
book, and this momentum,
and this week, and in general.
I'm feeling you're catching me
at a super interesting time.
I'm super emotional about
clearly in my stomach feeling
that I've taken another step.
A step in the journey that
I think is inevitable,
and I'm excited about it.
So, your turn out tonight
means a lot to me,
and so I thank you very very much.
You know, the ironic thing
that people don't know about me
is if there were 50,000 people here,
or if there was one person
here I'd fuckin' bring it.
(laughter)
You know.
I think when you're in the
business of marketing something
that you don't actually do,
it's all about listening
and asking questions.
Right?
So, the first thing I would
do is really try to understand
what I'm trying to accomplish.
So, if you ask me what I think I am,
I think I'm a counter puncher.
That's why I did Jab Jab Jab, Right Hook.
I think in nature I'm a counter puncher.
Right?
I'm trying to understand all of you,
and then I reverse engineer it,
and then I start stacking what I wanna do
based on what I know you want.
You know why a lot of you are here?
Because of all the other business coaches,
and all this, they're full of shit.
They're trying to hold
their best stuff so that
you feel like they're
giving you a little bit,
and they wanna suck in to
their fucking master mind,
and their fucking ebooks
and shit like that.
I'm giving my shit away for free.
Every three years I come and I'm like,
"Can you buy a 20 dollar book?"
(laughter)
Every one of my fans
and some of the people,
you guys see this, the comments are,
"Gary, alright, enough with the book."
I'm like, "Really, really?"
Like I can't throw that little right hook
once every three years.
(laughter)
For 90 days, I'm sorry,
I'm a real fuckin' asshole.
(laughter)
You know.
Meanwhile, these are the same people,
one guy really pissed me off,
and then I went and looked
at everything he's doing.
Same dude that bought
somebody's 300 dollar ebook
on Snapchat where the
guy stole all my content,
and repackaged it for 3 hundo,
and he's mad at me for
promoting 20 dollar book
a little too much for his liking.
Unfollow me bitch.
(laughter)
What people don't understand
about me is I'm a very
big time business man.
Like it's time for everybody
to start recognizing that
I built a 60 million dollar
business before I came out,
and started being a pundent.
Dave, I know, I love it.
Like, when I started my agency,
I built an agency since I've
been running it for four years
from 3 to 100 million dollars
in revenue on Madison Avenue.
Right, like, that's real.
Think about this,
I already had money when
I started VaynerMedia,
and because I was running a business,
and I was treating it like a business,
we started out of Buddy
Media's conference room,
so I didn't have to pay rent.
Like, entrepreneurs these
days are raising money,
getting all nice and fancy.
They're just trying to raise
money for the next round.
They don't have a business.
So, I like the way you
reacted to the newsletter.
Don't worry about how I'm doing it,
or anybody else.
Everything works by the way.
Not everything works for you, got it?
- [Woman] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(urban pop music)
- They don't wanna take it out--
- They don't want it!
- So what are we doing?
- We're getting it.
- We're getting it (laughs).
(urban pop music)